Якщо спитати в пересічного німця,
чи є у медицині корупція, відповідь буде "Так!".
Утім, розуміння хабарництва у цій галузі в українців
та німців кардинально різне.  Для українців це
зазвичай гроші або подарунки, які лікарі беруть, а то
й вимагають у пацієнтів. А також доплати
за шприци, аналізи, місця в палатах тощо.
У ФРН хабарів лікарям не дають. Утім, це
не означає, що корупції у медичній галузі зовсім немає.
У німецькій медицині деякі критики вбачають
корупційні схеми у відносинах фармакологічних
компаній із лікарями. Один із таких випадків -
так звані "спостережні дослідження".
Фармакологічні фірми офіційно повідомляють
низку інстанцій про намір провести довгострокове
спостереження, як певний препарат діє на пацієнта.
Ці ліки вже пройшли клінічні дослідження і
дозволені до вживання. Компанії укладають
контракти з лікарями, які - по ідеї - і так прописують
цей препарат. Лікарі протягом року-двох
документують свої спостереження. За це вони
отримують гонорар. Це в середньому 500-800 євро
за пацієнта протягом усього періоду дослідження.
Плюси цієї процедури полягають у тому, що інакше
зібрати додаткову інформацію про дію препарату
та побічні ефекти за такий великий проміжок часу
неможливо або надто дорого. Критики ж вважають,
що в лікарів з'являється додаткова мотивація
прописувати саме ті препарати, за дією яких вони
спостерігають. Хоча це карається законом.
Жорсткі борці проти "спостережних досліджень"
називають їх "легальною корупцією" в медицині.
Іще одна схема, якій закидають хабарництво, -
спонсорство фармакологічними компаніями курсів
із підвищення кваліфікації для медиків.
Німецькі лікарі зобов’язані регулярно підвищувати
свою кваліфікацію, щоб не втратити ліцензію.
Коштують такі курси чимало. Іноді  фармакологічні фірми
беруть на себе кошти за проїзд, проживання і добові лікарів.
Вони зацікавлені в цьому, адже можуть
прорекламувати великій кількості лікарів свої препарати.
Щоб уникнути зловживань, лікар, згадуючи
певні препарати в доповіді, зобов'язаний зазначити,
чи отримує він гроші від виробника цих ліків.
Окрім того, фармакологічні компанії можуть
поширювати власну продукцію або комп’ютерні програми,
в яких рекламують ліки власного виробництва.
Виробники ліків докладають максимум зусиль і
чимало грошей, аби медики запам’ятали саме їхні
препарати і прописували їх своїм пацієнтам.
Приміром, у 2017 році виробники ліків, за даними
німецьких ЗМІ, витратили близько
400 мільйонів євро на клінічні та так звані
"спостережні" дослідження і 105 мільйонів -
на курси підвищення кваліфікації лікарів та гонорари за лекції.
Гроші безпосередньо від пацієнтів німецькі лікарі,
на відміну від деяких українських колег,
не отримують, адже вся необхідна медична допомога
гарантується обов’язковим медичним страхуванням.
Воно покриває більшість необхідних медичних послуг.
Додаткові послуги як, наприклад, необов'язкові аналізи
чи більш якісні пломби, ніж передбачені страховкою,
пацієнт оплачує самостійно. Пацієнт зазвичай
навіть не знає, скільки коштує та чи інша послуга,
яку йому надає лікар.
Діти обслуговуються за рахунок страховки батьків.